the committee's focus was the 187
minutes between donald trump finishing
his white house speech to the followers
he'd summoned on january the 6th and his
eventual video message calling on the
rioters to go home after they'd reached
the capital
more evidences presented that trump
wanted to join the protesters and that
he got into a heated argument with
secret service agents who refused to
take him but now we got a suggestion
about why they refused from a security
official who chose to remain anonymous i
don't know if you want to use the word
insurrection coup whatever we all knew
that this would move from a normal
democratic you know
public event into something else
having been rebuffed trump retired to
the white house dining room where he
remained for over two and a half hours
the call logs are blank for that time
and the official white house
photographer was prevented from entry
but fox news was displaying the
unfolding chaos a few kilometers away
witnesses say trump made no effort to
intervene during that time but was well
aware of what was unfolding are you
aware of any phone call by the president
of the united states to the secretary of
defense that day
not that i'm aware of note
are you aware of any phone call by the
president of the united states to the
attorney general of the united states
that day no
be aware of any phone call by the
president of the united states to the
secretary of homeland security that day
i i'm not aware of that now
those in the white house were growing
more alarmed desperate to get the
president to do something so were
trump's children his closest allies the
republican leadership in congress even
fox news hosts but to no avail on
capitol hill members of the vice
president's security details say they
were terrified
members of the vp tell at this time were
starting to fear for their own lives
but instead trump tweeted an attack
against mike pence that inflamed the
crowd further it looked like fuel being
poured on the fire
donald trump's daughter ivanka managed
to get her father to agree to call on
his supporters quote to stay peaceful
but only after protracted negotiations
me that the president did not want to
include any sort of mention of peace in
that tweet
the committee argued that only when it
was clear that any attempt to stop the
vote certification would fail and the
national guard was on its way did donald
trump speak but even then he refused to
use the prepared statement it was a
landslide election and everyone knows it
especially the other side
but you have to go home now
we have to have peace see i can't see it
very well and the next day as he
addressed the nation trump still would
not conceive but this election is now
over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the election's over i
just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
the committee's argument is that trump
broke the oath of office by not acting
on january the 6th that he didn't just
fail to act he chose not to act and the
committee will hold more hearings in
september to make the argument that
trump isn't fit to ever hold office
again
shihabra dancing al jazeera washington